in this video we'll talk about the cell
injury and the causes of cell injury
this is a high yield topic for USMLE
step one stay tuned till the end of the
video and don't forget to subscribe cell
injury can be caused due to Cellular
stress when cell experience stress is
try to overcome the stress by doing
adaptation there are many methods of
adaptation but imagine a situation when
cell can't adapt to the stress
that leads to cell injury there could be
also obnoxious stimulus that lead to
cell injury there are two kinds of cell
injury irreversible and reversible
now in case of irreversible cell injury
the outcomes are apoptosis or necrosis
that means ultimately the death of the
cell these are extreme outcomes but in
reversible injury there could be repair
and cell can get back to normal in most
of the cases
so let's talk about the causes that can
lead to cell injury
in order to understand that we have to
understand things that can lead to
stress anyway stress can lead to chain
lead to changes in the cell
and cell can experience stress due to
external or internal change in the
environment
the organelles that are responsive to
stress are mitochondria ER nucleus and
plasma membrane
there are two kind of
outcomes towards stress that we already
discussed adoption to the stress or cell
death
first cause of cell injury is physical
damage like trauma like radiation or
let's say injury due to heat
second cause is hypoxia lack of oxygen
it could be due to anemia ischemia
cardiopulmonary failure or even due to
sewer poisoning these are few of the
causes of hypoxic reaction there could
be immune reaction that lead to killing
of the one particular cell type there
could be genetic disorders which make
cells more prone to stress and decrease
its ability to adoption
now there are several causes of cell
injury which involves infection
like viral infection parasite infection
bacterial infection there could be also
nutritional imbalance that can cause
cell injury
now cell injury often happens due to
stress
when it is more than the capability of
adaptation
now the extent of injury depends on the
nature of the stress
for example neurons are sensitive to
ischemic injuries than the skeletal
muscle that tells us there are cell type
specific susceptibility towards a stress
there could be also duration of the
stimulus that can lead to different
degree of injury for example slow
developing ischemia and acute ischemia
has different outcomes slow developing
ischemia leads to atrophy of renal
artery
whereas acute ischemia leads to renal
artery imbolus so we can understand the
diversity of the outcomes based on the
intensity and the duration
now let's talk about the reversible
injury and its features in case of
reversible injury ATP level drops when
ATP level drops the pumps the molecules
that requires ATP becomes non-functional
for example activity of calcium channels
and sodium potassium ion exchange pump
their activity drops
the ribosomal or polysomal complexes
that are attached to the endoplasmic
reticulum gets detached under this kind
of reversible injury
which leads to a decrease in protein
synthesis anyway plasma membrane
composition can also be changed there
could be alteration in the lipid
composition blabbing or even the
membrane Integrity can be compromised
nuclear changes in in the nucleus one
can see the chromatin gets clamped in
case of reversible injury that's a very
initial part of the injury
so overall all these cellular and
molecular changes leads to loss in
cellular function
in case of irreversible injury which is
more at one stage of injury it it leads
to nuclear degradation
there are different stages of nuclear
changes will come to it but anyway
nuclear degradation condensation and
fragmentation of the genome
there could be rupture of the lysosome
which leads to like bursting of all the
content of the lysosome which is
released in the cytoplasm could be
detrimental for the cellular physiology
there could be damages into the plasma
membrane or there could be
compromisation of the mitochondrial
permeability so what we learn in case of
irreversible injury the key Hallmarks
are loss of the electron transport chain
or dysfunction of the electron transport
chain amorphous densities or inclusion
bodies can be found in mitochondria
there could be chromatin condensation
and there could be also burst of the
lysosome known as autolysis
anyway nuclear fragmentation has
different stages this is how a healthy
nucleus look like stained in blue in
case of hypnosis there is an
irreversible condensation of the
chromatin and and the nuclear nucleus
actually shrinks there could be a
carrier axis which leads to destructive
fragmentation of the nucleus and the
debris are like
sparged all over the cytoplasm there
could be karyolysis which is complete
dissolution of the chromatin due to the
action of nucleuses so these are
different phases of the nuclear damage
any of these can be underlying a
irreversible injuries
so I hope overall this video was useful
if you like this video give it a big
thumbs up don't forget to like share and
subscribe make sure you check out our
Facebook page also check out our
Instagram page for free notes flashcards
Etc
you can support our
page via super thanks you can pay via
Paypal UPI or net banking see you in
next video